and up good boy y'all ready how's it
going everybody I'm John Bernthal this
is Bam slam the dog and these are my 10
Essentials
so these right here are my Bates combat
boots I first got acquainted with the
wonderful Bates company on my uh little
stint on Walking Dead much to my
illustrious publicist dismay I do not
get rid of these boots I love these
boots I wear them every day I'm a firm
believer in being able to run when you
need to run being able to move when you
need to move I like Comfort they have
this unbelievable uh zipper here so
that's the easy on easy off you can keep
them tied I can play basketball in these
boots I can work out I can box in these
boots I love them and I'm grateful for
them and um I'm a huge supporter of
Bates boots I would advertise for them
all day long for free the next thing I'd
like to talk about uh that is absolutely
essential to me is the most wonderful
fruit uh on the planet that is the
grapefruit I first got acquainted with
the the wonderful grapefruit when I was
living in Russia we actually have a
grapefruit uh tree behind our house
there's nothing in the world that makes
me happier than picking my own
grapefruit and then going to town I mean
I really want to peel this you know what
man [ __ ] it I I'm gonna peel this sucker
open right here I don't normally eat it
this way I normally do it with a uh with
a knife and I cut in half but like it's
the white parts that are really good too
so here's to you and uh Happy grapefruit
eating
all right my next item I want to talk
about is the yellow legal pad I love my
dad and I very much admire him and look
up to him and when I think about my dad
I think of this unbelievably uh tireless
and uh tenacious work ethic he always
made time for us always made time to
coach us to be there for us there was no
conversation you couldn't have with my
old man but he also he worked his ass
off always and he always started each
day with a a yellow legal pad every
movie every role I play I always put
everything down on these legal pads I
dig them and um I I couldn't go anywhere
without them so I'm very grateful to uh
the yellow legal pad my next item is
this little headband this is my
daughter's headband it's all stretched
out now because it's been hanging from
the rearview mirror of my truck she's
the center of the middle of my heart
she's my favorite human being in the
entire world she's perfect it's got a
little Diamond fake diamond in the
middle of the uh the flower here and I
don't know makes me think of her and I
love her so it's definitely one of my
essentials I don't go anywhere without
it yeah I don't um like to fly so when I
go away for for long periods of time I
like to take my truck and these are the
items that hang from my rear view um
they're my boxing glove being a boxer is
uh enormously important to me my best
friend Sean Kerrigan always tells me
going with the closed fist I always
remember it's a fight and um I carry
this with me to remind me of that these
dog tags here are from my sister Sarah
Wayne Callies who I did The Walking Dead
with this was my rap gift after season
two The Walking Dead was a a
unbelievably uh meaningful job for me
it's it's um the job where I became a
husband where I became a father and I
think it's really uh was the first step
in the most important section of my life
where I became really the the man and
the artist that I always wanted to be
these right here are worry beads these
are Greek worry beads uh for my best
friend Greg zumas who's been my best
friend since I was in first grade he uh
he brought these back to me when he was
uh 16 years old from his trip to Greece
that he took and he's my brother there's
pretty much nothing in this world that
we haven't been through together so I
carry him with me at all times and this
is uh in here some fur from my dog boss
who is my number one right-hand man he
and I went through it all together and
my dear friend Lauren uh got me this uh
when we lost him a wonderful dog a kind
dog and a Dependable dog so these are
the things that I have on my rearview
mirror when I'm driving to and from work
this is a very important book to me this
is a journal I got at a place called
ismalowski park on the outskirts of
Moscow Russia they sell anti-aircraft
missiles and live bears and stolen CDs
and Russian artifacts it's it's like a
whole city a time in Moscow was the most
formative time in my life I literally
wrote something down every single day
that I was there I only write in this
now when I lose somebody or the birds of
my kids or when something sort of
momentous happens I go back and I try to
read this every couple years and reminds
me really why why I do what I what I do
when I got this book there's an old man
he gave me a shot of vodka and we drank
it together it was freezing cold he's in
all this fur and he blessed this this
book one thing about Russia is uh
sometimes even when I couldn't
understand what they're saying I
understand everything that was being
said I know this book is is sacred and
will always be sacred to me so I take it
with me anytime I do a job this is
always with me this is uh the most
important person in my life that's my
hero and my best friend she you know
just makes me uh the man that I want to
be I take this with me to every job I go
to no matter where overseas I always
have it with me you know she is uh the
strongest and uh wisest bravest and most
honorable person I've ever met I'm so
glad that that um I'm in love you know
that I'm still in love after all these
years we've known each other 20 years
and she's my everything so this is uh
more than essential this is this is the
whole thing right here so yeah
definitely had to be on my list
I can do better
definitely don't underestimate uh double
bubble I I really can't say enough good
about double bubble um I am addicted to
it when I see it I have to kind of put
it in my mouth I am a big gum Enthusiast
I I'm constantly chewing gum on set this
is like a little burst of Heaven if I
see it in the store I gotta buy it I
love me some double bubble I I it
doesn't last that long but good things
don't always last forever you know what
I mean I just can't say enough good
about about uh double bubble do
incredible and I like because I like to
work out
I've been playing sports my whole life
and I've done all kinds of different
workouts but recently I've become a
complete believer in the Kettlebell and
my trainer one of the best women on the
planet Jeannie Leopoldo she put me on to
this this has totally changed the way
that that I work out I've worked out on
the side of the road in Mississippi and
gas stations you can get a cardio
workout plus a Weight Workout I love
kettlebells you'll never see me without
kettlebells nearby so
um yeah I'm a big big believer in the
kettlebell one of my essential items has
to be Bam Bam the dog I'm a big pit bull
guy I've always had them I always have a
bunch of them but this guy's enormously
special to me but we've been through it
all together oh [ __ ] man chill man we're
almost done dude I love you I love you
uh when I'm leaving work it's always
good to have a little piece of home with
me so Bam Bam the dog is many things in
this world and one of them is definitely
essential and for my next essential it's
definitely not a thing it's a wonderful
wonderful human being my head of
security Lauren elmark one of them
what's up so Lord Lord and me been
working together a long time we met on
the set of the Punisher Lauren was a
real one from day one there was a day
that bam bam got taken out of my trailer
and got lost and nobody could find him
he went over five miles across the BQE
everybody had given up but there's only
one person who remained with me at the
end of the day still looking and that
was Lauren she's been with me ever since
I don't do jobs without her she gets my
back my wife loves her my family loves
her now she's part of the family and uh
yeah she's definitely essential
thank you
guys thank you very much this has been
John Bernthal and my 10 Essentials
treats you and the essentials in your
life with Grace and kindness thank you